hey everybody Clyde and I are just
hanging out in the backyard trying to
make the best of this lockdown situation
I hope you are - whether you're locked
down quarantined or just roaming the
streets aimlessly real quick guys wanted
to offer you all a free month access at
Ruben report.com so you can just go to
Ruben report calm enter code at home 8
th om e at home and you'll get free
access to the entire community we've got
thousands of really interesting people
all over the world there we've got an
free video we've got at free podcast we
have a news feed that's completely not
manipulated by any wacky algorithm I own
all the content and the user data no big
tech nonsense involved you can
communicate with me you can communicate
with other fans we're doing movie
afternoons we've watched a couple movies
together and then we do a giant zoom
chat we watched movie contact two weeks
ago we did idiocracy last Sunday we're
gonna do a giant dinner night when we're
all gonna cook the same dinner and watch
each other cook and drink some wine and
have some fun and there's all sorts of
other interesting stuff happening over
there so you go to Ruben report.com and
enter code at home 18 h om e and you get
a month free access and hopefully it'll
make the lockdown a little bit easier
and I look forward to communicating with
you guys if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell